[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 que hoy dedicamos a la vacuna contra
el coronavirus hay gente que está
impaciente por vacunarse otros que se
preocupan por su fiabilidad y otros que
se oponen con un movimiento cada vez más
fuerte de anti vacunas el caso es que un
año después de detectarse los primeros
casos de kobe 19 han visto la luz varias
vacunas con una rapidez inédita en la
historia de la medicina y para
aclararnos las dudas que suscitan hoy
hace escala en parís el venezolano
daniel scott algarra inmunólogo y
biólogo en el instituto pasteur de parís
señor scott muchísimas gracias por estar
con nosotros conocido que el software es
a lo largo de la historia ha habido
reticencias a las vacunas incluso a
louis pasteur se le acusó en 1885 de
querer enriquecerse con la vacuna contra
la rabia incluso de haber fabricado la
rabia en el laboratorio en el caso de
coronavirus hay actualmente varias
vacunas cuatro ya muy avanzadas para ser
modernas astrazéneca y sputnik y rusia
china y reino
y ya comenzaron a vacunar a su población
una parte de la sociedad se muestra
reticente e incluso temerosa
porque vemos estas reticencias tiene que
ver con que estas vacunas han hecho de
forma muy rápida cuando normalmente toma
10 años en un año ya tenemos vacunas que
se están aplicando esto podría explicar
este este temor si primero que todo es
porque hay antecedentes de otras vacunas
que han tenido problemas de efectos
secundarios de efectos secundarios
graves y eso ha llevado a la población a
desconfiar de las vacunas
después actualmente en todo organismo de
salud han acordado que se pueden
funcionar algunos pasos
cuando se intenta hacer una vacuna para
ir un poco más rápido y esto lo que ha
pasado con las vacunas contra el
sarcoptes que es lo que se llama fase 1
y fase 2 en los estudios clínicos
estos estudios clínicos han funcionado
estas dos fases se ha llevado a una
producción mucho más rápida de
resultados según ustedes ha ido
demasiado rápido la fusión de esas dos
más no no creo que se ha ido rápido con
respecto a los antecedentes de otra
vacuna pero estos son va más el programa
permitido por los organismos fiables
fiables en otro factor que a lo mejor
puede explicar estas reticencias es que
para algunas de las vacunas se han
utilizado técnicas muy innovadoras que
antes no se habían utilizado en humanos
como el caso de los laboratorios
modernas y fisher esta técnica que se
llama el arn mensajero explíquenos en
qué consiste esta técnica porque se oyen
muchas cosas hay gente que piensa que te
van a modificar genéticamente incluso
que bill gates te va a poner un chip con
esa vacuna
en qué consiste exactamente primero que
todo hay que decir que esta vacuna han
sido ya te están en modelos animales
desde hace muchos muchos años ya hace
más de ocho años entonces esto ha
llevado naturalmente a que el proceso se
acelere en el humano porque ya habían
antecedentes de que esta vacuna eran
inocuas y en animales lo que se inyecta
es un lo que se llama un ácido nucleico
una parte genética el virus no el virus
entero o sea la parte que queremos que
el organismo reconozca dentro del virus
que son lo que se llaman las proteínas
de superficie y contra las cuales se
produce la respuesta inmunitaria
entonces ese adn mensajero entra en la
célula y hacia la célula para que activa
la célula para que produzca las
proteínas y que el sistema inmunitario a
la vez ya no te modifica para nada no
hay integración en la célula
y no hay el mecanismo para amar ser
enzimático de enzimas que lleven a la
integración de este reino mensajero
lo que provoca es una respuesta
inmunitaria con esa parte genital
pequeña parte genéticas de no es el
virus total de cómo va la vacuna que
está preparando
sanofi pasteur el instituto pasteur en
un principio tenía que estar disponible
en junio del año que viene y se acaba de
anunciar que finalmente no será posible
y que será no será hasta finales del
2021 cuando cuando esté lista porque se
ha parece que los resultados
no eran del todo satisfactorios si hay
que ver si la vacuna es estable si la
vacuna produce una respuesta inmunitaria
deseada y si la respuesta que se está
produciendo es capaz de proteger al
individuo entonces naturalmente en esta
vacuna probablemente no había una
estabilidad necesaria para poder
inyectar para poder comenzar en un
estudio de fase 3 por él
esta vacuna es una vacuna clásica no
utiliza el arn mensajero no es lo que
quiero que se entienda bien que esta
vacuna utiliza lo que se llama un vector
ya es una envoltura de otro virus que no
infecta al hombre o sea que no daña al
hombre y que adentro está precisamente
la reina mensajero del cual hablamos
antes y cuando estás en estas células se
infecta con este vector entonces el arn
mensajero hace la misma función que como
una como la vacuna de moderna o de falsa
en hay que temerle a las sales de
aluminio no sé si la de sanofi pasteur
las utiliza como un adyuvante de gigante
que también es uno de los temores hay
mucha gente dice las sales de aluminio
son muy peligrosas si las sales de
aluminio son peligrosas si se inyectan
en mucha cantidad y lamentablemente el
adyuvante o sea para aumentar la
respuesta inmunitaria necesitamos poner
esas moléculas que se dicen adyuvante y
en ese caso la mejor ayudante que
tenemos actualizas son las sales de
aluminio en el hombre entonces hay
muchas investigaciones para conseguir
otro ayudante pero naturalmente son
lleva tiempo para poder reemplazar la
estamos de acuerdo que con las
cantidades que se ponen en las vacunas
no hay riesgo para la persona el riesgo
es mínimo para las personas en que
quiere decir que una vacuna tenga una
eficacia del 90 por ciento del 95 del 70
que son estas cuatro que ya están
bastante avanzadas mucha gente que
desconfía dice bueno como que sólo tiene
el 70 por ciento de eficacia entonces no
me vacuno
en todo ensayo de medicamentos de
vacunas hay lo que se llama dos brazos
un brazo al que no se le da la vacuna y
un brazo al que se da la vacuna y
entonces la gente vive normalmente entre
comillas y entonces vemos la cantidad de
gente que se infecta en el brazo que nos
recibe vacuna y la cantidad de la gente
que se infecta en el brazo que recibió
la vacuna comparando estos datos
entonces pues se puede llegar a la
conclusión que las personas vacunadas
más del 90 o 95 por ciento de las
personas están protegidas con la vacuna
es lo que quiere decir es eso trato pero
recuerdo que hay lo que se llama la
inmunidad de de un grupo de grupo de
relación de rebaño en el cual entonces
si vacunamos a un porcentaje alto de la
población las personas que nos van a
responder la vacuna va a estar protegida
por las otras personas entonces a cuánta
gente hay que vacunar
a conseguirse que mínimo hay que vacunar
90 por ciento de las personas para
obtener un mínimo el 70 por ciento de
protección a esas personas
hay que vacunar a los niños
ahorita en el caso del cob y creo que es
muy temprano para decir si hay que
vacunar a los niños o sea todos los las
vacunas estas actuales lo que llevan
primero el primer objetivo es proteger a
la gente que tiene mayor riesgo o sea
gente mayor
con comorbilidades y también producir
esa esa inmunidad de rebaño en esta
persona y después un segundo objetivo es
proteger contra la forma grave de la
enfermedad o sea que la gente se puede
infectar pero hacen la forma muy leve
asintomática y no van a ir entonces a
los servicios clínicos de terapia
intensiva ya que no aconseja
actualmente no creo que haya que vacunar
a los niños cuánto dura la inmunidad si
nos vacunamos porque tampoco se ve muy
bien cuando hemos tenido con cuánto dura
esa inmunidad es algo que se sabe o es
que todavía no se sabe hay algunos datos
que se tienen con la vacuna de faith
sherwin un artículo que publicado la
semana pasada en donde ellos dicen que
tres meses después de la segunda dosis
de la vacuna hay todavía anticuerpos
capaces de neutralizar al virus pero una
claramente son datos parciales y muy
tempranos todavía o sea que no tenemos
tanta historia de las vacunas está nueva
para decir va a matar protegió por un
año seis meses hay diferentes cepas del
virus scott 2
la vacuna funcionaría serviría para
todas las cepas o como en la gripe se
tiene que adaptar cada año
no es completamente diferente hasta
ahorita de la gripe las mutaciones que
se han visto son mutaciones que no
implican las regiones contra las cuales
está vacunando entonces se espera que
esas regiones que son estables o sea que
son homogéneas en los virus puedan
inducir una inmunidad a larga distancia
en este caso se sabe si la vacuna impide
transmitir el virus es decir yo me
vacuno no desarrolló una forma grave de
coronavirus pero puedo transmitir la
enfermedad a otra persona
como dije antes si el objetivo de la
vacuna es para que la gente no produzca
las formas graves entonces la persona se
infecta y es potencialmente contaminante
y eso responde también a mucha angustia
que tiene la gente sin seguir utilizando
las máscaras o no incluso cuando la
gente se ha infectado por él por el sar
cotto
hay que continuar a utilizar la máscara
o sea que no estamos cerca de quitarnos
más cuerpos esto va para meses incluso
años tratados con mascarillas va a
entrar como entro en la cultura por
ejemplo asiática el uso de mascarillas
usted es un referente mundial en las
investigaciones contra el vih porque se
ha conseguido tan rápidamente vacunas
contra el sas co2 y aún no se ha
conseguido contra el vih hay una
diferencia fundamental y lo dije antes
es la capacidad de cambiar el virus en
el virus del vih tenemos mucha
cambio genético que se producen de
resistencia medicamento de resistencia a
la respuesta del organismo entonces es
muy difícil para conseguir una vacuna
que sea universal contra todas las cepas
del vih
además el el vih a diferencia del
coronavirus se integra en la célula lo
cual también hace difícil de atacar ese
virus a nivel del adn del material
genético que está integrado en hacer
bueno y antes de terminar doctor scott
yo lo voy a hacer la siguiente pregunta
usted se vacunará y con qué vacuna
yo me vacuno con la vacuna que sean más
eficaz y más segura y cuál es de momento
esa vacuna es la ya en el mercado
tenemos que esperar los resultados
definitivo porque les recuerdo que lo
que saben más de estas vacuna es lo que
ha publicado en la casa farmacéutica
pero no tenemos artículos científicos
que nos relaten la historia de esta
vacuna actual o sea que podemos concluir
que va a esperar voy a esperar un poco
más
bueno pues muchísimas gracias daniel
scott algarra director de
investigaciones del instituto pasteur de
parís por haber estado con nosotros
y muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet ene efe y
mundo.com y en france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos